[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu heute live ja wie gut sind wir
vorbereitet auf die zweite welle ist der
lockdown in berchtesgaden
ja ist das ein anfang müssen wir also
mit weiteren szenarien dieser art
rechnen
das sind fragen die wir stellen wollen
heute abend den fragen die wir uns jetzt
ausgedacht haben aber wir sind auch
immer glücklich über fragen die ihr uns
einreicht bzw
natürlich auch kommentare zu diesem
thema wir sprechen mit professor dirk
brockmann von der humboldt humboldt
universität zu berlin und darüber hinaus
tätig am robert-koch-institut er ist von
hause aus physiker forsch zu komplexen
systemen so zum beispiel auch zur
computergestützten epidemiologie
schwieriges wort und er beschäftigt sich
auch mit dem corona wir uns guten abend
herr brocken an einnahmen wir hatten uns
angesprochen berchtesgaden ist im
shutdown es gelten strenge ausgangs
beschränkungen ist das ein szenario an
das wir uns in der nächsten zeit auch an
anderen orten in deutschland wohl werden
gewöhnen müssen also generell kann man
sagen dass wir natürlich jetzt wieder
die letzten tage und letzten wochen
wieder in einer sozusagen beschleunigten
kassen sind wir hatten im sommer gesehen
dass die fallen
skifahren und dann das duell angestiegen
sind und jetzt sind wir aber wieder in
so einer beschleunigung reden vom
exponentiellen wachstum und das ist
völlig natürlich dass wir wieder alles
tun müssen damit wir kontakte reduzieren
und dadurch dass wir unser verhalten
wenn wir das ändern
erst in etwa zehn prozent lagen die
effekte sehen den fallzahlen ist es auch
zu erwarten dass natürlich in anderen
landkreisen dann auch wieder maßnahmen
getroffen werden die dazu führen dass
die fallzahlen runter geht
das ist wichtig wir sprechen gleich
darüber was in zukunft zu tun sein wird
wollen uns aber gerade auch noch mal die
vergangenheit anschauen nämlich die
dynamik der entwicklung in den
vergangenen sechs monaten
so sah die ausbreitung des corona virus
auf dem höhepunkt der ersten welle am 21
april aus als besonders viele menschen
mit corona statt
vor allem in bayern und baden
württemberg viele rote landkreise mit
mehr als 50 neue infektionen auf 100.000
einwohner in einer woche und so sieht es
fast ziemlich genau sechs monate später
aus hotspots davos im frühjahr keine gab
zum beispiel im gesamten ruhrgebiet und
auch in berlin
ja also das hat sich doch ziemlich
verteilt was fällt ihnen auf wenn sie
sich diese karte anschauen
ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger
unterschied den man hier in der
anfangsphase in der ersten welle hat
sich das virus sozusagen geografisch
verteilt und an verschiedenen ebenen
punkten gab es dann diese jetzt ist es
aber so dass über den gesamten sommer
sich quasi das virus überall verteilt
aktiv die zahlen waren und wir eben
durch jahr regeln und euch verschiedene
andere maßnahmen und unser verhalten und
jetzt darf ich dass das virus schon
überall quasi latent wieso nach
schwelbrand sich ausgebreitet hat
passiert ist das halt an verschiedenen
orten denn das virus wieder die
gelegenheit hat sich wie bei unsere
kontakte auszuweiten dass es dann das
dann da die instanzen also die fälle pro
100.000 einwohner über die stellen wir
gehen das ist genau das was man auch
gewartet und das ist aber auch eine
andere situation
wir gucken gleich noch auf andere
schwellwerte ich will gerade noch unsere
zuschauer auch mit bzw user mit ins boot
nehmen schreibt zum beispiel habe ich
ihn j auf facebook bzw es war über
youtube meine ich die maßnahme
deutschland sollen laut politik so gut
sein wie kann es sein dass asiatische
länder zum beispiel vietnam taiwan etc
bis zu schreibt er oder sie ein drei
hundertstel weniger fälle haben oder
liegt es einfach an den vielen testungen
und einer falsch positiv quote also das
ist eine super interessante frage ist
auch eine frage die sich viele experten
stellen und da spielen verschiedene
faktoren nach hause ich glaube
obwohl ich in diesem gebiet kein experte
bin das quasi das individuelle verhalten
eine große rolle spielt das haben wir in
verschiedenen asiatischen ländern
gesehen dass
schon sehr viel mehr verinnerlicht haben
dass sie sich nicht nur anstecken können
sondern auch andere menschen anstecken
können also zum beispiel die
bereitschaft masken zu tragen war da
schon gegeben wären das in europäischen
ländern noch lange diskutiert worden ist
ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist das ist
ein faktor und dann gibt es auch in
verschiedenen ländern sehr effizientes
sechzehnte kontakt rück noch folgen aber
ich denke die psychologischen faktoren
die sozialen fraktion dass sie sich
stark
als teil einer gemeinschaft begreift
dazu gibt es übrigens wissenschaftliche
evidenz dass das und asiatischen ländern
stärker so ist also das noch nicht
weniger stark als individuum wahrnimmt
und einer community
das kann da auch nach unter spielen
viele faktoren gut also vielleicht
gerade noch mal der appelle an die
masken muffel wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe das ist ein wichtiges
instrument
wir reden noch einmal über einige zahlen
die in den letzten tagen bei uns
aufgelaufen sind also die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist ja auch eben starke
angestiegen nicht nur die verteilung in
unterzahl insgesamt und dazu wollen wir
uns auch noch mal ein paar details
anschauen bevor wir dann gleich
weiterreden der sieben tage schnitt bei
den crooner neuinfektionen im frühjahr
erreichte er seinen vorläufigen
höhepunkt 5.840 menschen infizierten
sich damals täglich doch dieser rekord
ist geschichte aktuell liegt der schnitt
bei 6.320 tendenz steigend doch die
zahlen sind mit denen aus dem frühjahr
nur bedingt vergleichbar
denn zuletzt wurde mehr getestet wichtig
dabei die positiv rate mit april wiesen
rund 9 prozent aller tests eine
infektion nach derzeit sind es knapp 2,5
also wieder neue zahlen für uns wir
sprechen mit professor dirk brockmann
physiker und ja man kann sagen zahlen
experte er beschäftigt sich unter
anderem eben auch in dieser
computergestützten epidemiologie und
kann uns vielleicht eben auch diese
zusammenhänge noch einmal besser
erklären als wieder selbst könnten
herr brockmann haben da noch mal die
zahlen gesehen
wir haben zum einen die infektionsrate
wir haben zum anderen die positive rate
beziehungsweise auch die sterblichkeit
worauf stellen sie ab oder worauf sollte
man abstellen
ganz besonderem maße also man muss das
immer sozusagen als blumenstrauß von den
informationen betrachten die fallzahlen
sind ganz wichtig aber auch die positiv
test ist wichtig und auch wie viele
menschen dann im krankenhaus landen etc
das ist auch wichtig muss all diese
dimension betrachten aber was ganz
wichtig ist jetzt dass man die
kurvenverläufe betrachten ja eine kurve
gerade gezeigt der fallzahlen über den
gesamten verlauf der pandemie und wenn
man sich diese kurve anschaut und zum
beispiel vergleich mit anderen
europäischen ländern dann sieht man da
unterschiede wenn man sieht auch
ähnlichkeiten ganz viele wenn das sind
durch dieses tal gegangen im sommer der
fallzahlen dann einer starken welle
jetzt im herbst an kreis spanien und
dann auch mit verzögerung italien und
auch deutschland und aus diesen
zusammenhängen kann man natürlich viel
lernen aber ganz wichtig ist tatsächlich
die zeitliche entwicklung an kurven
nicht nur den erst wert das ist so eine
art foto der situation sondern der
gesamten verlauf das ist dann quasi das
video und videos wissen wir ja aus denkt
man mehr lernen als einfach aus
standbildern und das ist wichtig aber
man muss auch alle dimensionen betracht
man erkennt aber in den fallzahlen
alleine das noch ergänzen das nicht die
dynamik jetzt gemerkt geändert in den
letzten tagen gab es da eine
beschleunigung das reicht aus sich aber
viele zahlen anzurufen wirtschaft mit
mehreren test dann nur wenig an der
stelle noch mal ein user kommentar bzw
eine frage die aber wohl stellvertretend
eben für mehrere user steht einige
fragen das dominique sperren diesem
falle auf youtube die whu uhr spricht
von einer sterblichkeit von 0,2 prozent
ohne dass ich das jetzt nach prüfen
konnte warum hört er nicht auf also sich
mit dem thema zu beschäftigen meint er
wohl ja also es gibt ja ganz ganz viele
aspekte es gibt ja nicht nur die
sterblichkeit ist ja nicht so dass man
das kriegt und dann so viele menschen
sterben sondern es gibt immer mehr
wissenschaftliche kenntnisse auch über
langzeitschäden
die sterblichkeit ist selbst sehr
schwierig zu schätzen das kann auch
regional sehr unterschiedlich sein es
kommt auch die altersverteilung anders
alles gar nicht so einfach eine zahl
super partie wie schwerwiegend die
folgen einer solchen pandemie sind und
gerade langzeit schädigung die durch
eine comic 19 erkrankung dann nachhaltig
entstehen kann man gar nicht abschätzen
das heißt man muss halt auch da ganz
klar die unterschiede zur grippe sehen
und ich bin da kein experte sondern
leser dass mediziner in diesem bereich
machen aber das kann man ja verstehen
dass hat ist es eigentlich auch der
gesunde menschenverstand der haben sagte
wenn es zb langzeitschäden gibt dass man
das dann auch als eine gefährliche
pandemie ein rauchen wollte und im
übrigen haben wir das nicht in der hand
auf diese an dem sich ausbreitet oder
nicht in diesen delhi die durch unser
verhalten dafür sorgen dass die
dynamisch wird oder wieder aufgebrochen
ist eine frage die auch immer wieder
auftaucht auch von unseren usern im
vergleich zum april beispielsweise wird
natürlich auch wesentlich mehr getestet
und die frage ist inwieweit das wiederum
die ergebnisse von heute auch
relativiert oder inwieweit man das
berücksichtigen muss ja das ist auch
eine gute frage und auch hier muss man
wieder die kurven anschauen gesehen wir
haben ja im sommer einige monate etwa
500 fälle pro tag gehabt und dann gab es
eine zeit in der die testung von sagen
wir mal 300.000 auf 11 12 millionen
angewachsen sind
dann hat man auch einladung allen
anstieg in den fallzahlen gesehen quasi
als spur der vermehrten testen wobei das
auch nicht so eindeutig zu belegen
aber dann gab es einen bereich in dem
die erst um quasi konstant blieben aber
dennoch die fallzahlen explodiert sind
in dem sondern das jeden tag
der zuwachs der größer geworden ist und
das kann dann nicht mehr nominiert
werden durch die zahl der test gut also
müssen wir festhalten an den alleine
gestiegenen test aufkommen liegt es
nicht dass die zahlen gestiegen sind
neben den neuinfektionen bevor wir
gleich weiter sprechen gibt es ja
womöglich zumindest das ist auch immer
mal wieder umstritten auch andere
parameter die zur beurteilung der lage
womöglich herangezogen werden sollten
auch das haben wir uns noch mal genauer
angeschaut intensiv bettenbelegung
todeszahlen etc
während des frühjahrs stieg die zahl der
menschen die intensivmedizinisch
behandelt wurden auf 2.935 danach
flachte die kurve ab aktuell sind es 8
179 menschen
die zahl der todesfälle erreichte am 21
april ihren bisherigen höchststand 248
menschen starben damals an oder mit dem
corona virus gestern waren es 29 gestern
waren es 29 also die sterblichkeit so
scheint es jetzt im moment deutlich
niedriger ja wir erstmal hängt sehr
stark von der altersverteilung der
menschen hat die aus vitali siert werden
das war anders am anfang der pandemie
und jetzt aber wir sehen auch bei der
sterblichkeit chor und das war ganz
interessant dass in die dekore gezeigt
haben den anstieg jetzt im herbst und
wenn man genau diese kurve die anschauen
und berücksichtigt dass die fallzahlen
explosionsartig also experimentieren die
höhe kommen oder gehen könnten dann ist
man rucki zucki wieder bei den bei den
zahlen die man im frühjahr in den
exponentiell heißt ja dass in gleichen
abständen immer mehr leute infiziert
werden und dann ist man ganz schnell in
diesem größenordnung das sieht man an
der kurve auch da sieht man wieder vom
verlauf kann man etwas ablesen und man
kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen heute ist
die situation besser als genau an dem
und dem datum im frühjahr in dem man
einfach die fälle oder die hofft dass
spezialisierung vergleichen das ist
nicht genug man muss die verläufe
anschauen
und da sieht man dass auch hier jetzt
wieder ein anstieg stattfindet wir sind
noch nicht wieder da
was die zahlen angeht wie im frühjahr
aber das kann ganz schnell dass hier um
das vielleicht auch noch mal zu
untermauern was sie gerade gesagt haben
wir haben ja auch noch einmal eine
grafik vorbereitet was die korona zahlen
so nach alterskohorten angeht und da
fällt eben auf das gerade bei den
älteren das ist hier oben die
dunkelblaue bzw graue schicht dass das
vor allem eben im april und im mai einen
stark betroffene alterskohorte war das
wurde dann deutlich weniger im verlaufe
der zeit da war es dann mehr die
alterskohorte 15 bis 34 da wurde es
immer dicker aber wir sehen jetzt wird
die wieder schmaler und ab
duell geht die zahl bei den 80 plus
jährigen doch wieder nach oben also wird
dieser teil des diagramms sozusagen
wieder dicker das müsste uns ja dann
auch zu denken geben wenn die zahl der
älteren wieder stärker betroffen ist
weil dann eben auch die sterblichkeit
wieder steigen könnte
generell ist das halt risiko und wenn
die betroffenen werden und das wächst
jetzt wieder ist das auch ein indikator
dafür dass sich das virus viele in der
gesamtkalkulation ausbreitet und damit
als dann auch wenn diese altersgruppe
trifft in die dann aber sehr starkes und
wirklich betroffen ist aber noch mal es
gibt auch andere altersgruppen in
anderen altersgruppen
immer mehr information rein dass eine
kuh mit 19 infektion nicht harmlos sein
muss auch wenn man sie halt überlebt
oder auch diesmal ins krankenhaus muss
kann es sein dass man langzeitschäden
davon trägt auch in anderen
altersgruppen das heißt ihr könnt das
nicht so schwarz weiß man es gibt die
älteren menschen und diese risikogruppe
um dann eine rechte population bei denen
die infektion eigentlich okay so kann
man das nicht denken noch mal war wie
gesagt die user gerne mitnehmen wollen
jedes jahr im winter schreibt auf
youtube major jedes jahr im winter
sterben leider mehr menschen besonders
alte und kranke
die frage ist wenn keiner nach
coronaviren suchen würde hätten wir dann
eine pandemie jedenfalls eine über
sterblichkeit gibt es gegenwärtig nicht
meint dieser user das deckt sich
allerdings jetzt auch nicht mit den
informationen die ich in der letzten
zeit so aufgenommen habe da gibt es wohl
eine über sterblichkeit oder was ist die
expertenmeinung ja also das ist einfach
nicht richtig also erstens um diese
hypothese dass wir davon nichts gemerkt
hätten das halte ich für ausgeschlossen
dafür gibt es auch verschiedene andere
beispiele aus der historie wo es neue
epidemien gab eben dann uns anderes
virus 2003 h1n1 influenza pandemie 2009
das märz virus das passiert das wird
schon erkannt weil ich halt effekte hat
das ist nicht so das geht an einem nicht
so spurlos an den wissenschaftlern oder
den experten so
vor über das wird erkannt und bei den
über sterblichkeit ist es so dass man
tatsächlich hier ja fälle hat
da braucht man gar nicht auf die über
sterblichkeit zu gucken wie er marxist
das indirekt gemessen wird die
klimastrategie
hier hat man halten menschen die direkt
an cockpit 19 sterben und dass das ist
einfach sowohl das kann man einfach
sozusagen direkt arten hier hat man
sozusagen direkten kausalen zusammenhang
kommen wir mal zu dem was uns jetzt
vielleicht in der nächsten zeit
beschäftigen oder auch leiten sollte wie
wir uns verhalten sollten weitgehend
einig sind sich die wissenschaftler ja
darin dass vor allem eben auf die
verfolgung von gruppen von sogenannten
clustern wert gelegt werden sollte was
das genau ist und auch warum dieser
ansatz so wichtig ist das wollen wir uns
auch noch mal genauer anschauen
eine familienfeier im geschlossenen raum
es wird ausgiebig gefeiert was keiner
weiß vater und tochter sind mit den
corona virus infiziert über den abend
hinweg stecken sich weitere personen an
das cluster ist perfekt spricht eine
ungewöhnlich große anhäufung von
infektionsfällen an einem bestimmten ort
zu einer bestimmten zeit die große
gefahr
mehrere infektionsketten könnten jetzt
auf einen schlag beginn zb wenn
infizierte personen andere gruppen
kommen etwa beim arzt oder beim sport im
schlimmsten fall droht durch neue
cluster ein rasches exponentielles
wachstum
es muss also reagiert und die ketten
unterbrochen werden etwa durch
quarantäne
doch wie gut erkennt man solche cluster
und wie kann man die fälle nachverfolgen
tja eine offene frage und da wäre ich ja
blöd wenn ich sie nicht direkt
weiterleiten würde an sie also die frage
der cluster nachverfolgung die gut
funktioniert die das kann ich nur schwer
beurteilen also wir beschäftigen uns mit
der modellierung und den effekten die
solche klasse zeigen in computermodellen
bei denen man dann zb untersuchen kann
die wichtige clusterbildung erstmal das
wurde jahr zeitweise diskutiert und alle
modelle die man dazu entwickelt hat die
zeigen dass erstens tatsächliche messung
von kontaktnetzwerken die aber auch
schon jahre zurück liegen zeigen halt
dass menschen hat sich bewegen fasst
dann bewegen also wir sind halt soziale
tiere und deshalb machen wir diese
clusterbildung was ich aber einen
modellen zeigt ist das sozusagen die
reduktion von den clustern deutlich
stärker aus und auch die eindämmung der
pandemie als man vielleicht erwarten
würde
also wenn man zum beispiel eine gruppe
betrachtet von 50 leuten und reduziert
diese gruppe auch einfach nur die hälfte
25 leute dann in der kleineren gruppe
nun schüssel der kontakte und das ist
sozusagen das feld der stärker ist als
man vielleicht erwarten würde also
gruppen reduktion geburtstagsfeier
machten 20 kindern und entscheidet sich
dann ich reduziere wird auch die hälfte
und machte nun geburtstag feiern zehn
kindern dann hat man sozusagen ganze
risiko also die hand verdeckt möglichen
traditionen um einfluss reduzieren wo
sie es gerade das ist der richtwert
brocken an das sollte ich gerne um das
noch mal sozusagen abzustützen oder auch
nochmal grafisch zu unterfüttern auf
eine grafik zu sprechen kommen die von
ihnen ist bzw ihrem institute haben
nochmal die ansteckung möglich keit in
gruppen und wir sehen hier das kennen
sie in einer gruppe von 36 personen gibt
es 1260 mögliche ansteckungswege und
jetzt kommt genau das ins spiel was sie
gerade schon angesprochen haben sie
können das gerne selber kommentieren
falls sie es sehen können bei sich der
halt ganz ich kann ganz gut erkennen ich
habe auch so ein bisschen im kopf also
wenn man einfach sagt man hat eine große
gruppe und teilt sie in zwei kleine
gruppen
dann hat man die kontakte etwa um 50
prozent reduziert und teilt man das
jetzt auch den nächsten club sterne auf
die ursprungs gruppe entschied dann hat
man die gesamtzahl von kontakt noch vor
sich immer noch genauso viele menschen
letztendlich treffen nur in kleineren
gruppen hat man das ein viertel
reduziert und so weiter und bei 9 und
andere noch mal genau deutlich ist dann
etwa 90
man kann aber dass noch extremer machen
der die aussage ist eigentlich die das
wenn man sich entscheidet statt sich mit
20 leuten zu treffen nur mit zehn leuten
treffen dann wird sofern die kontakte
geschüttelt also der effekt da noch viel
stärker in diesem modell verzichtet ja
keiner auch sozusagen das treffen das
sind immer die gleiche anzahl von
menschen die sich nur in unterschiedlich
großen gruppen treffen da es auch schon
direkt stark aber nicht ganz so stark
also wir halten noch mal fest ist lohnt
sich jedenfalls größere gruppen zu
reduzieren und je weiter man das auf
splitt um so besser ist es eigentlich
ein hinweis noch den beitrag den wir
gerade gesehen haben falls euch das noch
mal besonders interessiert mit den
clustern das ist noch mal zu sehen in
der zdf- heute- app lohnt sich das noch
mal sich etwas ausführlicher anzuschauen
vielleicht nochmal stichwort
rückverfolgung das gesundheitsamt in
dortmund hat uns heute gesagt ab etwa
100 infektionsfälle pro 100000 einwohner
kann die rückverfolgung im grunde nicht
mehr gewährleistet werden das sind ja
immer so richtgrößen ja auch für die
politik wichtig sind was können die
ämter noch verfolgen und was dann eben
nicht mehr weil ja auch oft der vorwurf
ist 50 60 70 das wirkt alles irgendwie
so willkürlich aber dass mit diesen 100
deckt sich das ungefähr auch so mit
ihren einschätzungen können sie das
beurteilen
das kann ich nur schwer beurteilen weil
ich in europa folgen prozess nicht
kennen
aber es würde mich jetzt nicht
überraschen wenn das so wäre deshalb
glaube ich also fangen auf der expertise
die ich beisteuern kann weiß ich dass
sozusagen jetzt endlich die appelle an
die bürger kommen müssen dass man
versucht die kontakte zu reduzieren weil
die kontakte das sind wovon dass wir uns
nicht und überlebt und in allen
kontexten indem man das machen kann dazu
sich auch die rückverfolgung wichtig
dass man schauen kann
in welchem war diese person in einem
cluster geschehen bewachte ganz viel
mehr kann man erreichen indem man den
sozusagen wir quasi als behörden und
bürgern als gemeinschaft und entscheiden
das ding einzudämmen und jeder muss dann
halt mal auf 50 prozent der kontakte
verzichten oder überhaupt auf kompakte
verzichten ist das nun mit der
relevanten sehr stark wir nehmen noch
mal ein paar user mit rein caroline
grujic schreibt auf facebook die whu rät
vom lockdown ab und nun fragezeichen und
jo am 7 12 auf youtube sind
grenzschließungen sinnvoll um die
ausbreitung zu verlangsamen also
lockdown grenzschließungen sinnvolle
maßnahmen oder eher weniger
doch dann bezieht sich ja immer auf
verschiedene maßen andy hill mal über
das die reisebeschränkungen weil ihr
auch viel diskutiert worden
es gibt verschiedene modelle auch schon
seit jahren die zeigen den effekt von
reisebeschränkungen im situation wo ein
neues erscheint irgendwo auf der welt
oder einer bestimmten region und überall
wochen das noch nicht und da zeigt sich
dass reisebeschränkungen durchaus ein
effekt haben und das verlangsamen wie
das für sich den anderen betroffenen
region ausbreiten
diese situation haben wir haben eine
situation in der das virus zwar nicht
genau gleich überall im land verteilt
ist oder in europa es gibt es
schwankungen manchen regionen sind
stärker betroffen als andere aber
dennoch ist es überall
das heißt der effekt von
reisebeschränkungen ist zwar da aber
vernachlässigbar gering im vergleich zu
effekten die zum beispiel diese cluster
reduzieren oder die kontakt beschränken
dass man so viele menschen trifft oder
masten machten prägten die auch nicht
nackt reduzieren also reisen beschrieben
haben einander situationen wird was
schon so geografisch mehr oder weniger
gleich verteilt ist kein großes
wenn wir es jetzt nochmal plastisch
zusammenfassen wollen gegen ende der
sendung welche maßnahmen würden sie
jetzt auch rückblickend auf die
vergangenen sechs monate wir haben
am anfang schon einiges gemacht machen
immer noch vieles welche maßnahmen
vielleicht auch eben für die zuseher und
user draußen sind sinnvoll und sollten
ganz besonders stark umgesetzt werden
jetzt in der nächsten zeit also mein
appell geht halt an alle sich klar zu
machen dass man auch über tragen kann
und dass man sich dieses bild vor augen
führt dass letztendlich das virus wir in
der hand haben können indem wir unsere
kontakte reduzieren denn das virus ist
ja nicht so eine sonder unkontrollierte
gasleck die sich über das land gelegt
hat sondern das virus lebt von unseren
kontakten und damit lebt es von etwas
was wir kontrollieren können und das
muss sich jeder klar machen jeder kann
sondern jede person kann einen eigenen
beitrag leisten indem man die kontakte
reduziert vorsichtig ist aha regeln
befolgt und wenn eine starke kontakt
reduktion stattfindet dann sieht man in
zehn oder 14 tagen sieht man auch den
effekt blieben nicht vielleicht zum
schluss noch eine persönliche frage
patrick auf youtube fragt ist der herr
brockmann frustriert von den ganzen
corona leutner sternchen innen und
denjenigen die experten wie ihn
persönlich angreifen
vidic ist ihr fell gar nicht so dick und
ehrlich gesagt
und du bist beschäftigt mich schon und
und ich verstehe es nicht also ich
versuche das dann als
naturwissenschaftler immer auch als
naturphänomen zu sehen was die leute
auch die straßen treibt und das sind was
sie glauben und das ist ja auch ein
internationales phänomen man muss nun in
die usa schauen
das besorgt mich ungeheuer nicht was
gesellschaftlich der abgeht völlig
unabhängig von von corona von der
pandemie der phänomene die irgendwie
auch was miteinander zu tun haben auch
wenn doch unabhängig sind
ja und das besorgt mich ein trip durch
auch aber nicht mehr halt durch da
müssen wir durch und wir versuchen
gemeinsam mit ihnen und mit anderen
experten die gruppe zumindest der
leugner kleiner werden zu lassen und wir
hoffen wir haben mit diesem gespräch
heute abend einen beitrag dazu geleistet
vielen dank dafür professor brockmann
war das von der humboldt universität
berlin dankeschön für dieses gespräch
und euch legen wir noch die 19 uhr
nachrichten natürlich ans herz wir sind
ja heute vor den kollegen dran auch da
natürlich mit den neuesten updates und
informationen rund um die entwicklung
des infektions geschehens in deutschland
euch allen vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und fürs mitmachen
wir wünschen euch einen schönen abend
und sagen schau bis zum nächsten live
stream